my thing looks so cute hey guys
everybody yeah oh hey you seen on your
phone okay we're gonna start the show in
three two good morning Millennials if
you are watching this on YouTube we are
so sorry but honestly it's not our fault
YouTube was down all day yesterday
apparently they are still down you
cannot get our live stream to work but
we can do it from our phone so we are
going to lose all of our fancy cameras
that literally cost us 1 million dollars
to set up but we're live so that's all
that matters it's Friday we're really
sorry but hopefully this is good enough
yeah I mean it's better than nothing
it's better than just doing the podcast
[ __ ] like absolutely nobody wants right
now I know nobody nobody needs podcast
so no one means audio nobody they need
this attendant they need the Fox they
need the doctor got you I do think
people genuinely need to be inspired by
my beauty and that's what I'm here to do
it'll be a model for society yeah so we
like took the time to thank you today we
weren't gonna let that go to waste by
just viewing and audio recording exactly
but thank you guys for stay with us
we'll chat a little bit make sure
everyone can get on live here think so
off center or even they [ __ ] up
whatever they live over lie and that's
all that matters this is really just you
know this is live television people you
know feel scratching his ass on our
brand-new white carpet our live stream
barely is working but we're alive and
we're live and that's literally all we
can go for can I see what we look like
my phone is doing the live stream you
know he usually knows the queues when we
do ten that let me count up for 10 and
we start
and we always like gets into positions
but now he's just like walking around
because oh yeah that's great and you
guys can hear us we just have to talk
about for the YouTube live stream but
whoa okay I mean what dorama you know
that's that's not television that's all
I could say you know Rachel McAdams
didn't just you know turn good day today
and remember that show us into the
number watch on television things take
time
things take time but we're here and this
is such a Friday news yeah I'm looks
wedding from all the excitement yeah I
don't respect that breath
well happy Friday everyone welcome back
to the we toast we miss you we miss you
we hope you guys have enjoyed this
week's episode we had a ton of content
this week because me at dr. Burke's we
had this snap Charlie people are really
responding very positively the snatchers
appearance on our show yesterday you
know I think that she's a little
hesitant so I come out like the day
after she got laid off and just talking
about of it I don't know what's so
relatable people are getting laid off
left and right and has absolutely
nothing to do with their ability for
myself but I guess specific news that
our camera is [ __ ] today because you
can't see it's part of my psyche also
it's tire a genuine employment it was
for the bleach state that's so there's
something wrong with this coffee cup at
7:00 is when I take a swig too hastily
it like flies out this guy you're an HD
trailer
it's a crazy it's a crazy thing I know
this [ __ ] was such a treat yesterday
treat sure everyone loves a little
snitch on the topes boat above a snake
John the toasted John the toes but
that's right snitch on the toast if
you're ever feeling down
like I'm feeling down like five times an
hour these days yeah just staying snitch
I'm toast you guys
well feeling in your soul I've been
feeling down pretty much all week but
yesterday was my best day wanting to
date and on sales really inspired by
that some of the messaging you gave me
after yesterday's shows talking about
how money wash my hair and that just
kind of led me to wash my life you know
I believe my house immaculately like
literally vacuumed mopped scrub toilets
like same I scrubbed my shower this is
soap scum is what it's called early I
was not bad hands and knees exactly but
then people he was like did you use
gloves and I was like we have gloves Oh
hands and he's using a paper towel and
my hands were cramping like every
crevice in my apartment i vacuumed then
I Swiffer then I score rocks I clean
everything I did my peloton I was so
productive I mean I'm thinking in my
apartment okay so I live Lou so
productive that I clean my house
I couldn't metal body my face I felt so
that I shaved my legs like I was just
feeling like I needed to get out of my
body I wanted to be someone else so then
my house was an applet and Ben's parents
called and they ran out of toilet paper
and Ben didn't want them to go out so
Ben ran to like a grocery store by their
house and thought that toilet paper and
that grocery store was deserted and had
just restocked on kosher meat so Ben had
a party literally he got ground beef
ground turkey chicken burger and I was
at bed go crazy
he said no like I'm
crazy because other people went crazy
and I couldn't get me yeah I'm gonna be
responsible but he came home he got
bursaries and we literally disinfected
every piece of food that came into our
house we reorganized our fridge our
freezer and then we cooked a feast and
it was just like I feel like I'm not
quarantined like human beings should I
live in a clean house and I'm eating
real food and I'm having a bowl of
cereal for dinner every day you know I
am like cooking I'm just I was so
exhausted by the time I got done
yesterday after I cooked tell the time
cleaning from top to bottom shower to
change my sheets duvet cover etc and
then I like got into bed now I been on
my feet all day like I couldn't I
couldn't function and then I also I
watched Keeping Up with the Kardashians
and First Wives Club in the living room
so I didn't get into my bed till 10
o'clock
also I ordered on Amazon over a week ago
a mattress pad for my bed instead of
having some major lumps in my mattress
that there's no can't order not just
right now so I got this like fancy latex
saying it arrived yesterday too so I got
into like a new bed with a new body in a
new apartment and it was just so new
that's so that's so nice so it was like
a very productive day for me too then
afterwards have a psyche so just eat it
I didn't feel that I was just like sad
oh no I loved it I felt exhausted like I
haven't felt tired from moving and also
wanted to talk dance which got me really
sad I was savage classic bougie ratchet
and Nancy acted stupid what's happening
she what's happening
so between all the activity I was just
genuinely tired at 10 o'clock and that's
not a feeling I felt in a long time I
haven't been tired from moving in over
two weeks yes that's very very true and
I started a new book last night
Pittsburgh already but I just kind of
want to read all weekend and that's not
gonna take me long enough so I started
this book when we were mermaids it's for
young from the Kindle unlimited and it's
actually really good feel like I haven't
gotten it into a good book I've been
reading like mediocre books and it's a
good feeling to get to look I love I
love it so we are obviously going to
deliver the Fast Five stories for you
we're going to recap the premiere of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
I am technically but actually and Kim
tweeted back at the lash manuals work
I'm also gonna recap the choice will be
in the day which was First Wives Club
Eddie Jackie and I are on the same page
and I don't want to disappoint people
because based on its around us people
were like yeah but not last night maybe
I just wasn't in right back space but
the energy the movie was just way too
frantic and then you need to come to
hotel well that's what we were saying
Diane Keaton is always pleasure
characters she was playing that
character but I don't know totally just
like Bette Midler if you are going to
literally come to my house and the
gardens over and like stab me she's just
like I couldn't take her energy oh you
know what of all the characters she was
only one I can tolerate
I like Goldie only because she was also
rational and yeah and Goldie Hawn say
lipstick and cigarettes and hair and the
alcohol was that making me look if I was
around her if I was in that friend group
I think would be able to look her in the
face and heard about it yeah she was
discussing like I couldn't take her and
then Dan Keith was just like being
stolen away any decisive in forensic and
so then I was luckily Ben did learn it
was a little bit ahead of her shoulders
like holding almost discussing like I
but I didn't never really see how flimsy
between golden Iman and Kate Hudson
until this movie not that he doesn't
success he but they were just talking
really similarly and I was like oh
that's her mom
yeah totally a movie kept at the end but
like we have to say and I'm not saying
that it's a bad movie I'm just saying I
didn't like it last night no I'm not
saying it's bad news recap yeah okay
because I like but I wrote on all my
books about keeping up the Kardashians
and First Wives Club on my phone which
is being used to livestream so I guess
I'll just go back it was just have to
wait in okay well without further ado
now there's really no concept of time
how long can be then life or who even
knows the comparative so go ahead and
say that each ease time tape fast have
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bank at your morning
toast the podcasters got the crunch the
video people did not so let me allow it
now this would normally be the time of
the show where I would have something to
say but you know times are tough brands
are just they're not spending like
videos to so to be honest you would
always wanted to give a sense of
transparency with the audience I had
absolutely nothing to say because if
nobody's fun so you're not going to step
up my cookie cannot marry poppies no
Daenerys got one pair of Robbie's Betsy
my Rockies you can throw in the wash
machine but in Dragon with eggs original
song I am running low on time are you
yeah so I have a lot of show that you
want okay I make me some are you doing
laundry every day
no week I was sticking to my website
schedule but we're going through more
clothes than usual because when I wear
like a blouse on the toast I'm put in
afterwards because it's about taking it
out softly now malaria bujjamma
every single day end up wearing the
pajamas for 20 hours a day so I'm
watching watching my pajamas every day
but sometimes I'd wear something just to
sleep and then I'll wear it again the
next night to sleep you know I'm psycho
pajamas of course it's real life but not
as hearty like oh you all know because
I'm wearing them for so many hours of
the day when mo and deodorant either
like I've eaten jamás and nike jamas
yeah I would I'm like done with my
activities for the day up like shower um
and for coffee given time you doesn't
know just like my evening pajamas your
evening wear yeah so I'm doing more
laundry more towels or showering in the
default each hour you do and it leaks
out to the floor I'm like really bad but
it's just getting worse and worse it
works until like every time you shower
gives an acid puddle so that we have to
lay a towel down so now we have eight
towels well Ellie and we're running low
on time do you have is the water coming
out of like under is there a gap between
the floor and the bottom of the door no
it's like there's a step
yes and it's just coming down to
stablish I don't know I don't even know
how it's getting out yeah it looks a
seal you know I someone she had like
somebody handyman Oh weird I don't want
to say like I'm just gonna magma and
learn on glass because I they're they
literally have [ __ ] us so hard we
didn't talk about this beneficent in one
year ago Jesus he keeps on sending
different people and coming to get
different quotes because every quote is
like kind of a just I guess it's a
really expensive thing to do okay it's
your apartment I can fix the shower
finish out before it starts leaking down
below and it's gonna get moldy fix it
was this little rose
no no we did this is what this girl's
doing how she bigger red okay oh I
already said without further ado over to
my stories oh this is weird
today's episode is just having a hard
time I can find them I don't know I
can't find them okay
I don't remember what I said because our
first story of the day Prince Harry
Maggie Merkel sleek rotavirus in Canada
for California so even is that we all
saw coming but you know some people on
Melanie Bromley didn't believe is that
Megan and Harry are moving to LA I mean
this is obviously not shocking we knew
she wanted to just become a to start go
to the Met Gala but it does seem weird
time it like me as of today the US has
the most confirmed cases of coronavirus
why that's a trend she flock here from
Canada when Canada's I think a little
bit better off but he might wake you I'm
saying right because Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau just announced that the
country's borders are going to be
closing so that means that she won't be
able to get to Beverly Hills she's been
going on in her move it's not about
corona it's like she wants me to LA he
closes the borders she that may put a
halt for three months on remove to LA
and she's that big big plan
by the way like no matter how big your
plans are look none of them can become
tradition right now everyone's party
actually this is nothing's gonna stop
this girl also love that she touchdown
they may be formal announcement what her
partnership with Disney is she's
narrating one of their movies they just
announced two movies yesterday one of
them navigate on the Corbin the other is
going to be narrated by they quote her
out as Megan Duchess know some say so
last name anymore which I thought you
looked able to use Duchess of Sussex
poet efforts that elephants and it's
being produced by Disney Pixar and she
is narrating it so I love those movies I
watched like our content every night
before bed and I'll probably watch this
one too but honestly when it comes to
nature and animals the only person I
want out reading the documentaries is
David Attenborough the old British man
he's just sensational
you know I said the Morgan Freeman of
Britain I'm excited to hear Megan's
voice and now they're calling her Megan
one named Wonder and touches the sausage
but I think it's because I didn't he's
grown at times like the Queen's not
going to be like throwing sound like
what's the word legal trademark
intellectual property infringement Bert
knows it's been a yeah no I know hold on
I was like once someone who's known for
away yes the kitchen I can be getting on
the tinges no her son has two rotavirus
like yeah she's getting exactly she is
busy so I feel like they're taking the
opportunity could just go hard with the
name did they say when they breaches
moving into large everything else she
she she
oh really she would be out in Hidden
Hills like the security no she's moving
to Mary think I think I'm telling you
this girl hasn't she does but you know
what I feel like Harry is been wanting
to live in Beverly Hills for a while
like he's always been somewhat of a
recluse is that fragrant and he's always
been the celebrity more than he's ever
did a royal because he's never had no
claim to the throne so I feel like he's
just as excited about this move like he
is just as thirsty as she is yeah also
like Mickey's mom lives there she's from
there until they know each other is
totally fine just like why did you guys
pretend you were moving to Canada like
what why where what's little I know what
was it the pit stop in Canada no ladies
to us I think we're being like they're
sponsors but like if you here's some
girl number two I would be in third
sponsor go hard or go home
in order to stay home in the words of
the original thirst monster Lisa Rhetta
oh yeah just own it I'm the thirsty
[ __ ] alive and that's what I call other
people thirsty like I genuinely don't
mean it as like the hustle so much but
hiding behind your thirst as if it's
like a genuine like reaction to
something or a genuine motivation like
that's where I feel like they're so you
can be negative but if you have only
thirst so you one thing you want money
to go does it right you're just human if
you're thirsty no come on I'm trying to
be like no we're gonna live a small life
in Canada you know very reclusive give
us some privacy on there just a liar so
then you're a liar and then you're
Camille you're such a [ __ ] liar
Camille sources are saying quote this
move was planned for some time we
realize Canada would not work out for
various reasons and they wanted to be
based in the Los Angeles area when the
big girl is kind of wouldn't work out
yesterday where they moved two days ago
like I can't attend an igloo [ __ ] wet
this is from this house I have no time
for the lies we have no time for the
wedding to me neither
you know even though we have only time
yeah they have a big support network
there it's where their new team of
Hollywood agents and PRS and business
managers from there's so [ __ ] shaving
Meghan has lots of friends there and of
course her mum Doria well that's the
most important part of a delicious
product so basically it's just her
moving home so clean even not be a
thirsty movie she generally just wants
to be at home with her friends and
family but what was the delay over in
Canada I just need to some congregation
could they might get a direct flight no
and I'm at the house with it
living in a cycle waterfront nobody sits
on its own Island I often play it was
stunning what are you doing yeah it
wasn't it like someone else's house like
they were never planning it was just
their temporary home it's not where they
belong pictures and room that I'm
passing through passing through this is
just it's like honestly so beautiful can
I just say Thank You Claudia that's
beautiful the trend of doing gender
reels on to talk to Carrie Underwood's
beautiful wonderful perfect American
astray I absolutely love and I just want
it like that pregnant and have a girl so
I can be a gender-reveal with that song
like I'm claiming it it's so beautiful
um that's really crazy I have no idea
died that was a trend and then it's a
boy well they choose something else but
then it's like the job is on it with the
kid and it's like I'm gonna have to have
your finger we had the beautiful
wonderful it's just sensational Wow yeah
I'm just trying we are so messy today
but you know I think it's better that
there was no sponsor like no one who I
mean attached to this piece of trash
thank you guys everything happens for a
reason
okay the next story is a story that I
was like feeling so touched by because
the New York Bake Shop is selling
doughnuts with dr. Anthony oh my god
that's a very young a picture of him
yeah dr. Anthony
and one of the nation's leading disease
experts continues to work on the
frontlines to inform in teaching about
the current virus pandemic now faculty
man's face can be seen
I'm sorry Benjamin Spock can be seen on
the front lines of a local donut shop as
a way to honor the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Disease donuts delight in
Rochester New York which was actually
the epicenter of the New York Obermeyer
cases introduced a new collection of
donuts featuring without cheese botch it
just started as a Trudy the shop owner
said it started as a thank-you but it's
sitting and I think it's great people
are stuck at home and what's happening
is it's starting conversations whether
they pick it up for someone it starts
that thinking outside of the box and
giving back okay but I just feel like
wanted to say what a major you know
fitting here and that's dr. Burks Macedo
cupcake well she's just this prestigious
working just as hard as a smart like
excuse me like even more beautiful than
ever know what it's like is it because
she's a woman
yeah I would need to think that New York
bakery whatever you're called I would
hate to think that as well I also saw a
take target charters melio eating a
piece of card okay so that's my tip if
you want it so bad so when I do like
that groceries next I going to get
myself a mini card okay oh my god and
it's any crazy this morning and it
really affected my day maybe that's why
I like I felt that this morning they did
last night but I would eat myself
because I just wanted to know like where
my hat and my doing anything right or
wrong with a nourish I need to know if I
like what I'm doing because I've never
eaten like this in my life where I'm
making my pasta but I also have but the
peloton in my house room so it's just
really confused and like I I couldn't
even see myself in the marriage you know
the results
what I'd like someone write about
they're not going to so save yourself
you know like I presume honestly like I
I didn't know they won't be there and we
had dr. Burks on this show and I still
oh no and I can only see in a global
perspective that's so crazy to meet that
like that's so interesting that she came
on this show she recognized us and they
didn't recognize oh no I'm not gonna do
anybody way no definitely not
I'm joking my special about like one
thing related to my weight like and they
don't even say the way they're just say
like it
yeah I'm general ballpark and I still
want to die but it keeps me up at night
that's gonna come out soon and like
people are gonna know like around funny
joke but sometimes you just gotta
sacrifice your own like sanity and
protection for a big joke and it was a
good joke like me it's just some people
what I wait just to shake things up
screams it's just a key or a window
shade Chicago yes oh you bet three
guesses and if you get it I will tell
you how tall are you I am 5-1 okay so
the BMI is like they see you like 105 by
the way I don't want you to be offended
at all
no trick ability which I'm hoping that
you don't get it right because in my
mind that I should weigh like 100 pounds
that I know so guy I was in Thirsk you
like view it like a bleep but I'm gonna
stay like one you're so small like 116
wasn't it how you learn I don't want to
say because I'll give it away
okay
it's too hot that's so great and we got
a little air is so much more that you
don't know myself
113 120 no but it's in between 1/3 it's
in between 1 & 2 the little ministry
let's leave a little mystery that I
actually wouldn't need to know I'm the
same way like I mean no it's not my
mother every 100 pounds I can't see wait
I'm in - he was um well it depends like
when you're waiting and a lot of rooms
gives my way down oh God
squirrels right I'm meeting they're
setting their own ways oh that would be
beautiful trying to start let's just
blend out yeah you guys do it all the
black on a normal table if it feels
being walked every day he usually weighs
about not one story he usually weighs
about like eighteen nineteen pounds
he probably weighs about twenty
twenty-one pounds now just because he's
not gonna he's deficit his full hour
walk and this is not a hair cut his hair
does weigh a lot so I mean I you know I
love him except to that anyway but I
would say prefer him to be a little
lighter because I can't use any yeses
yeah her back is bad yeah and he's just
like smaller he can still like on the
edge of the couch but he's limited by
his way right now but again I love men
exercise I'm very very size inclusive
yes um anyway so the moral of the story
is like I feel like even though I'm not
eating great I mean you want cards
actually because cars are keeping me
fall and then I don't have to like make
as many meals well I think like making
my own food is really healthy I think it
is too you know even if it is pasta with
cottage cheese was trying a together
maybe
you know what's going into it yeah and
it's like really not so bad I feel like
I'm not eating like the healthiest meals
but I'm not eating huge amounts bibury
so that's a good lesson to be learned
and developed on that when he helps yes
I did a great class yesterday I'm
actually looking forward to doing
another one today okay next story which
mean he's so mad when I read my
newsletter this morning I just can see
by the way we're using our microphones
Britain podcast listeners because
they're still armed Oh bless you even
though there are many podcast listeners
in these we'll get some more podcast
listeners the video Watchers
okay grocery store throws out thirty
five thousand dollars worth of food that
woman coughed on in a twisted prank a
woman played a twisted prank at a
Pennsylvania masseuse Laura and Sam I
purposely purposely coughing about 35 K
worth of food which had to be thrown out
the supermarket said [ __ ] [ __ ]
today it was a very challenging time Joe
the school wrote on the Facebook page of
Garrity supermarket chain which he combs
where where's the supermarket of support
of Pennsylvania Pennsylvania was called
Gary's scary a woman who the police know
to be a chronic problem in the community
compassion being described as by the
police proceeded to purposely [ __ ] on
our fresh produce and a small section of
our bakery meat case and grocery Oh
authorities are working to get that
woman tested for coronavirus he said
while there is little doubt this woman
was doing it as a very twisted prank we
had no choice but to throw out all the
products she came in contact with court
working closely with the Hanover
Township health inspector we identified
every area that she was in we disposed
of the products and thoroughly clean and
disinfected everything she's had to pay
back a three and then she should be
arrest
in prison for life I generally think
that people who like do pranks like all
the time or like are known to be
pranksters are [ __ ] sorry we talked
about that
that's I like who he said like French
youtuber he picks up celebrities and
he's always beating pranksters and
whenever he report on it I always see
the same thing if you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like if you're an adult and you
still think that doing prints like the
coolest thing that you can do like
you're an absolute loser never know the
prashna Chanel fashion show like I
didn't think that was funny like I
thought she's an [ __ ] so these are
the types of people who I just generally
dislike and in the age of quarantine
like how dumb are you like all these
stories that youtuber who licked a
toilet seat and as a joke end up getting
tested positive for curtain bars that
basketball player who touched all the
microphones as a joke ends up getting
tested for coronavirus positive like
this is not the time to be funny this is
not a joke I want your friends sounds
like you're funny you're [ __ ] away
yeah and like just the word prank i
scandalous instead that i've heard
actually like it's just not gonna be
funny you know i by the way there's a
difference i'm pulling prints on your
friends and pulling pranks on strangers
like sometimes I'll get videos on my
Instagram following page with like
random like youtubers doing pranks on
people in the street and honestly it's
not funny like printing random strangers
and you don't know it's not okay like
printing your family they gonna break
your sister I totally get it
giving it a video is funny play to
embarrass a random stranger you don't
even know don't even have their consent
like who are you I hate pranks yeah same
agree so I do love a prank phone call
right now and then that was like a
full-term activity when I was in middle
school
yeah well I mean
before you have an iPhone app keeping
busy like yeah and then that was before
they were app set to detect like it
could take down that starts at 7:00 and
show you it was really calling yeah and
also that was the 14th time like if you
had to talk you wouldn't be bothering
then you'd be like I'm Savage plastic
bougie ratchet and like this acting
stupid what's happened to what's
happening okay next we're even a
exciting but like is it rihanna releases
new music for the first time in three
years of setting bands because she
released a song with partynextdoor she's
a teacher on the song obviously I
remember once and you want them from her
but this is what we're getting for now
you said it perfectly Bucky very
exciting job is it I was excited
and then I listened to it and she's like
very on it and it's unfortunately I had
other expectations but unfortunately it
is just nothing of the sort
saying it hate to see it you know what I
listen to this morning than you do a
live album not as good as what I listen
to
there's five seconds of summer I can't
wait to do that as well the new tool we
found was really good it's reminding me
I feel like she's gonna like come back
this a lot but it's very like Lady Gaga
she is to me like the Millennial Lady
Gaga from her whole bread life obviously
the music but the costumes and the
dancing like she really reminds me of a
a more chunk down like Gen Z Lady Gaga
yeah I do I like the album it's too full
of bangers I love her vibe and it's
great it's just funny when she's like
singing these love songs and they're
probably about the voice
and Marvin D and I just like think of
him as like guilt on his little son from
Beverly Hills and it's like this
heartbreaker no no he takes like
everyone he gets like klenda that I
could but to me he's just like you know
13 years old Bella's brother
balus lil bro totally you know and he is
just like such an interesting guy you
know what does he do every day I think
he models and then he probably takes
photos with his friends and snacking on
like disposals yeah and you probably
like those restaurants and has yeah I
would think so and we think he has some
beetles here there I just feel like you
get bored a lot you know yeah
I didn't a lot of people would be bored
a lot but now everyone's like pretending
this is the first time you're bored and
Quarantine that's my favorite thing like
toto and don't spend all day all night
in their house and pretend like this is
a new sensation
totally I'm feeling very much at home
during the morning about it a lot of
time I say go device and my life isn't
actually like that different in
quarantine like there are times where it
is a lot different this is your
husband's home
yeah really true but there are people
who are in just sight oh my god I'm home
long time we can do it that's a way you
know it's really not that big of a deal
but just really quickly get back to the
5 seconds of summer album
absolutely sensational Baker after
manner like these dudes they couldn't
put out a bad song even if they all put
their cuts together and tried you it is
so good I absolutely love them I love
all the disables that came out for the
album and they really like gave a good
vibe from what that was going to be
inside there's rock there's soft there's
an that like it's just sensation there's
frog there's people there's Caesars yes
there is and you know what sometimes
this is a French reference this little
fire by the ferns Lone Rock it burns
rock
I'm a savage classy bougie ratchet there
was a bit story that I can't seem to
find a link to it was about how the
hallmark company is giving away million
cards that people can write like nice
steps and like send them to each other
during coronavirus kurta mattress um if
I believe it's really not that important
it's just like a nice thing in its home
market and also like I'm really hot and
over this whole YouTube set up so let's
just go over it let's quickly dive into
the First Wives Club which was our tryst
movie of the day just not really iconic
you know it wasn't a bad movie by any
stretch and to be honest when it all
made its way to the end like when they
were all getting revenge I did like that
I stopped halfway through and I thought
I wasn't going to finish it but then
everyone was like the last scene is
iconic costume design and I was not I
said I owe it to everyone to finish a
movie and it was cute thank you like
might watching the 90s would have been
part of mine yes my soul but it's kind
of like maybe how the people who watched
Heartbreakers for the first time last
week watch it last week and we're like
what is this movie oh yeah I didn't
think that a lot of people felt that way
I think people thought that way I feel
like just when you see it when you're
younger or at the time and it's like
everything of the sort now like 20 years
later it's just like okay
yeah I think unless you saw it at an
impressionable age it's hard to be
impressed by it now I just need tiny
movies that's it that is a that's it
unless you saw it at an impressionable
age it's hard to be impressed by it but
you never quote me like I was just yeah
just obviously destroy that it was
yeah I love the jet Sarah Jessica Parker
like whole thing she was actually like a
good actress but it's so funny how she
has had one role in her life but of
course she's done other things but she's
never really done anything other than
sex in the city and she just is the
state of matter with success Carrie like
she can't not be Carrie look even this
way she wasn't putting your hands on her
chest was like like what is the term
superhuman baby also what is morning
from oh he's the daddy clueless thank
you Oh Victor Garber was in that I love
him um it was gonna start something it
wasn't bad and I do not enjoy it new
short enough that it didn't bother me
that's your thing you like my songs no
no I'm sorry in this day and age you
can't keep me off my phone for two hours
also was the the friend who killed
herself
Rizzo from Glee I mean from very oshi
made a bit I think it was I just thought
I was really gonna like it like these
fabulous New Yorkers and he just ended
up being absolutely nothing of the sort
yeah just because I'm not invincible so
I wasn't impressed also ninety Smith
being like the socialite helping them
out that was okay that she's like from
the crowd right yeah but like just the
energy was just so frantic I can't cry
through night everybody
wouldn't they were going through that
house and they were upstairs in the
office and they come down there anyway
screaming downstairs slamming doors and
running upstairs with their heels on and
the day and he was just like I just see
her it's like the thing that side of a
she's so nuts it's like throw her on to
the window washer think she's Russia was
annoying me just the whole thing was
like not it unfortunately when I hate to
say it but it just wasn't it but I did
like the ending like it all culminated
in a nice way I'd loved when the
daughter said to me dad from seventh
heaven who's also a child molester like
hey Ted I'm a lesbian
hey she can't she kept them behind daddy
understand that the daughter was great
did she that helps a lot but like just
the way that she talk daddy daddy
oh also at the UM I liked how they had
real like New York feminists or whatever
like yes where he's trying to Gloria and
Ivana trauma
yeah cuz she I guess she's like these
that was made us white of scorned women
yeah yeah exactly she's up for the her
site so it was cute I just anything I
just didn't get it and I know I'm really
disappointed people absolutely loved it
but I just like once again I was not
impressed maybe because it wasn't
intentional yeah I would totally agree
with that
oh but I'm not saying it's bad to me I'm
just saying I did maybe I just was like
not in the right head space you know I'm
not saying it was a bad okay I'm just
saying like it wasn't for me yeah I
somebody agree
but I didn't not enjoy sitting I can't
display it was all very weird
yeah and it actually never seen Goldie
Hawn in a movie before a second act
I never saw it yes yeah so our side for
the weekend is gonna be something a
little bit longer instead of the movie
would've been to a series again last
week it was self-made and this began
jacking in good call to do little fires
everywhere because they released three
episodes last week one more this week so
maybe we could do it for the next few
weeks
yes so we can like have a few things
episodes to watch I'm even watching ten
weeks I just finished a book there's
four so people are saying that the show
is better than the books like I think
the show is probably big it is so I'm
excited to watch it so we'll watch as
the absence as there are there your goal
of resources I know but in the book like
in the beginning like I've never cards
where I love her but then
let it go oh look at all these cars
whenever she like a pail of sunshine to
me two of them be she owned this place
like the same exact kind of character
and like it's me yeah someone who's like
so together together but like so
internally not together yeah um and just
like typing just like obese I don't know
but I really yes she does have a very
similar role to her role is the same as
even in the other VM choreography book
that we read the husband secret Celia is
Reese Witherspoon big little ice and
yeah the exact same character um so I
hope you guys like that choice Keeping
Up with the Kardashians premiered last
night I love it on the first day I just
wanna say it was like honestly I was
watching them made me so happy that they
are my happy place and like I absolutely
loved it as a family like I love every
single thing about them from their head
to their toes and it just this we were
arguing a lot about Kim and like the
telescope stopping to just confirm that
like these are my [ __ ] people like I
love this show so much I don't love this
family like I can't stress it enough I
agree I love talking about on my street
they were looking something I was
watching it in my living room but I'm
usually watching my bedroom but
something about the skin and everything
was just elevated like it was so
saturated and beautiful and it was love
at Kim when she first of all heard of
fashion he was so excited I was I could
not get a kids show one hour just kept
like the life is just so fabulous and
let's see all the intricacies of dinner
and Tristan like it was just fabulous
and that Alpha Chi born to me looks like
that chainmail um sure and then repairs
look back I just thought that was like
the most fabulous she's ever looked and
I was loving just watching her being a
gal about town you know and then you go
back to New York and we're going to tell
them we're basically in the last season
like it's a safety pin roll to the back
of my head that they're being even more
transparent and they were
season like Chloe literally would
perky's [ __ ] [ __ ] instead of saving
her professional like this is a show
she's into the crew like oh by the way
the advice a cheeky Courtney was
saturated by a gratitude prayer before
you wake up it'll change your whole day
I love you know like I need to implement
that in my life every day
Courtney is just so out of control it
she has to go she is going right so we
were confused as to whether or not when
Courtney made the announcement was that
supposed to signify at the end of last
season but notes obviously clear does
that announce it is coming yeah but we
have to get them soon enough
um to be honest like Courtney was
bothering me so much because I was
thinking the corny probably is busy but
she doesn't not do it English she has
bouche or whatever but we see all the
time that Kim Kourtney Kylie kendall
doing work with the modeling kind enough
that we see good American shoots we see
all that I don't they ever seen Courtney
actually working it's like this show the
day of her birth and they didn't even
show our traditional digest and she just
sat in klamath what is her busy day no
but here's the thing these showed up on
group busy her like only busy day where
she was filming for the show and she's
shooting Architectural Digest
she hasn't she Architectural Digest
everyday so like what about the other
six days of the week this is like the
second one she's upset
I'm sure you guys have it I have it
sometimes where I have a CJ but just
like what she was complaining about look
I didn't sympathize I totally respect
someone who wants to make a decision
regardless of what financial place there
are now if you choose to be a stable mom
like that is that I totally agree with
her on that
but her reasoning makes no sense like
what she was complaining about was
sitting in glam yeah who cares you know
the press you could be the bottom clip
stable mom still still do it or don't
clam if you would like so anti glam and
just don't wear makeup you should learn
two things you like your hair just do
your makeup we've seen everything on go
like she'd be wearing makeup that would
be fun too so I didn't understand the
show I look when they're like more
relatable soon I just didn't understand
what she was complaining about during
last night's episode and we're back
again with the boundaries and a few
boundaries and in the final scene I
didn't think that the kid was being in
just as she had started with what she
said she said something Shady and then
said it again I'm Gregory right but she
she said something and she corrected
herself but then she explained the
correction again and she didn't happy
like she could have been like Chloe and
I work this hard but she like had to get
the insulted again but you know and I'd
be like wonderful her - including your
whole [ __ ] family a career and one
one person is ungrateful you can make
those sorts of comments
no but also bet they'd like their
sisters you can make those comments with
the reactions so it doesn't matter that
Kim was well you check them they start
on this particular argument because for
me it took me to a level calling her fat
literally beating her up getting
physical digging your nails into her arm
that I'm here what led up to that you're
wrong but that's always how about us
Elliott what Kim said even though this
like [ __ ] starting at me like it wasn't
in credit and Courtney could have just
like our be with her instead no I
they're gentlemen right and but I
understood what kid was there's a level
of work ethic and like human Chloe are
above and beyond like literally on
another visa Kendall is a very hard
worker but like Kim and Chloe when they
used to like go to everything nice to go
to Australia they used to do stairs they
used to do meet and greets in Singapore
trip and they would do anything they
hustled so [ __ ] hard they went to Kim
according to Miami buh-buh-bah look good
yes Kendall worked hard and she has a
very robust schedule and she's a model
and she's hard-working but like it all
he's like all these opportunities just
happened like she never had like spend
almost 10 years just working working
working and getting olds know it right
and I feel like don't Kemah works just
as hard as that but I think it's
different in the sense that Kourtney and
Kim and started Khloe and Kim do all
their work for the sake of the family I
think would have hopped on a plane for
Kylie to go to Paris if it had made
sense right and they were able to like
Kim I mean Kylie and Kendall and Kylie
and Kourtney just be just like flow on
to their dream jobs like without really
putting in the initial foundation
Kendall and Kylie are we're like just
when they decided to start working they
were a list with a-list opportunities
and Kim and Chloe and at times with
Kourtney worked themselves up from the Z
list yeah from Z to y 2x teed up all the
way up to the a-list they walked so
Kendall Kylie could run right and so
Kendall Heather are running but they
don't have that walking ethic yeah Kim
and Khloe have yeah but she nice know if
Kourtney it's Kylie and Kendall would
have never worked that hard to get to
that place well they don't know who's
been into Saturday but the shadiness
like to me like that's a conversation
like she could have had
no but the shadiness was obviously
directed towards four [ __ ] or he was
there for those years but she's just
like not doing it anymore
and I just started interesting that now
Kendall and Kylie are even Anatole the
first episode but they're much more
integrated into the storyline then
before I wonder if that has something to
do with Courtney's taking a step back
when it comes to the bomb on stuff like
go like it's a chance to fly commercial
like you didn't plan anything sorry you
have strep throat I have had strep
throat I have look worse except though
but a pack of prednisone can give you a
few hours of energy like go look she's
going to the hospital next week so it's
more than that I'm not gonna say that
she should go or not go but again like
Kim and Chloe would go because like
that's their like who they are worse
it's like they will go but like for
Kylie I feel like and I need to say this
but it's more of like an easy come easy
go sort of thing that she's a billion
dollars okay maybe this is a
multi-million dollar deal but you know
what she can't she doesn't feel like she
can go so she's not gonna bet right and
the deal will generate multi but she can
sell out whether or not she knows and I
don't know if she should have gone
around because you know what to
sacrifice your help just to walk in a
runway show to promote a collection
that's gonna sell it isn't necessary I
don't know I don't know but it's like
it's obviously look at Kris is freaking
out so much you thought it seemed really
important it's not just another collab
it's not the Jordan woods makeup palette
it's really important their relationship
with Olivia and Beaumont is obviously
really important because Chris is
offering
kindred actually for two thousand
dollars in a jet like without a
commission like it's obviously important
to me I'm not just a regular you and I
want to do things that like in the grand
scheme of things like there was a missed
moment because when I think back on the
kind of all-mountain collection he just
kind of like fell off the face of the
earth it's irrelevant
it obviously is thank you most sold what
they mean but it wasn't an iconic
every no she wasn't that because she
wasn't there and she didn't walk and the
amount that they coupled like he just I
remember even seeing the Fashion Show
and it was pretty nice
although it was men and now every once
in a while she posted a bomb on that
every Instagram because that was
probably based into the dealer so make
she were calculated and be there like
the Baxter and the whole thing is met
yeah I agree I love love love how they
film mostly a clubhouse close house is I
can buy aesthetic it is so light so airy
car outdoor furniture side so [ __ ] so
just like this is a huge property but it
feels so clean I love everything like I
think she's my favorite interior
Courtney five is like interesting but
it's not my personal vibe kids on yet
also very interesting but I wouldn't
want to look there I love Khloe and Kris
copies I can Chloe the most like it's
the statement plush rich big oversized
by like even that chair in Chloe
spectrum where they have the fight where
Kourtney and Khloe are sitting on the
stadium with recliner it's Louis
Eisenhower everything is just oversized
and plush and they love her house so
much I can I love that they thought
their wooden in that iconic right in the
media room last season where they're all
eating the candy that's Khloe's I think
it's just so delicious like that's where
my warranty oh oh stop this terrible
live stream oh I agree
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning trust the Millennial morning
show but people have Monday through
Friday Friday at 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so every watching this on
YouTube right now thank you for putting
up at this [ __ ] please subscribe to
us and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available is a product that's
anywhere podcast we counted on spotify
itunes stitcher public radio all radio
cash box all the places so everybody
listen to podcast fine dust morning to
us leave at 5:30 about a beautiful study
on smart we are
next week we are scheduled to the live
at 12 p.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
make sure once again you're following us
on Instagram for all the updates at the
morning shows and subscribe to us on
youtube at morning toast if you guys so
much fun amazing weekend stay safe stay
home
follow us on Instagram yeah those are
the best things you can do definitely us
on Instagram